foreign
is in Birmingham hey Ryan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
what's going on hey what's up
hey man so I just had a couple of
questions for you uh I recently have uh
quit gambling and uh I'm kind of in the
hole right now and I just need some
advice
what kind of gambling were you doing
oh specifically uh double deck Blackjack
uh and a fair amount of Poker Texas
Holdem online
uh no sir
um no sir how much have you lost
uh I'd say about a year ago I had like a
four day stretch where I won and lost
about six figures
so you recently quit gambling tell me
about that what's that mean
uh I'd say I haven't played cards in
about two months
um and my debt to income is great I just
keep putting myself in the same uh the
same hole yeah
you've had a gambling problem and you
just decided I quit and that's it that
that's all you've done so what'd you
backfill that hole with
um man I I am behind on Grant uh three
Corvette three car payments uh I owe
probably about twenty five hundred
dollars to friends of mine and uh right
now I'm just kind of living check to
check
but you quit gambling 60 days ago so
what six months ago six months ago what
have you done in the meantime that has
continued to make your your life
problems so challenging
well so I took a loan from a friend for
about 10 grand and then I was paying him
back payments after I'd lost that uh
large sump of money and uh so I've been
kind of paying him back when I can
um and then my student loans just said
I've got about eighty four thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt what
do you mean that's about
uh probably around I'd say I'm in sales
so I'd say this year I'm on track to
make about 150. okay and you're single
yes sir okay how old are you
I'm 22.
what have you
been going to Gamblers Anonymous or are
you seeing a therapist or anything
uh I just I had my first uh meeting with
a counselor a Christian counselor of
Wednesday could I have another meeting
next week oh okay good I appreciate it
that's what that's what I was worried
about because okay good yeah my dad he's
a pastor and uh man he acts like he
doesn't have two dimes to rub together
but I mean he'll he'll definitely retire
a millionaire for sure uh and it's it's
hard to talk about my finances with him
uh because he'd be so so angry with me
uh you know and so you know I kind of
just accepted the fact that I needed
help and good
um I'm upset with myself so time to make
some changes for sure an important part
to get an important part of getting well
is finding
um this word gets thrown around
culturally so
um I don't mean in the uh
never tells me the truth kind of way um
it doesn't hold me accountable kind of
way but part of getting well is finding
a safe person or safe people that you
can actually say hey I'm not all right
and I've dug myself a mask and um
sometimes our dads aren't that sometimes
our moms aren't that sometimes our
spouses aren't that it doesn't it
doesn't relieve us to the fact that we
gotta go find people and I'm proud of
you for doing that man yeah that's very
important part of this conversation Ryan
now now that you've done that what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
move from chaos
which this out of control feeling that
an addiction gives you and the chaos
that results in your finances and the
chaos that results in your career and
the chaos that results in your
relationships you're trying to move
wisely from chaos to order
you're trying to bring order to these
different areas of your life that's at
least what you should be doing but it
sounds like that's what you're asking to
do and I'm proud of you for that as well
so the thing we're going to do with your
money is we're going to put you on a
very strict budget where you don't get
to do anything except pay off debt and I
want you to list your debts smallest to
largest and start paying them in that
order and I don't want you going out to
eat I don't want you in a bar and I
don't want you doing anything except
working
and uh getting these debts cleaned up
did you say your three car payments
behind or you have three cars
um three car payments behind uh I I my
next check hits tomorrow uh can you
bring it current with that check
um so my rent I I spent about 1500 a
month and bills uh and you know now that
I'm behind how much are the car payments
uh it's 259. okay so you need 750 what's
your check gonna be
uh it's gonna be about after it's
actually about 9.87 it's my draw so I'm
on a two thousand dollar draw and then I
get my commission at the end of the
month
um
okay you have any money in your account
now much I have about 100 bucks to my
name right now okay I want you to take
it and you haven't paid the rent yet
no sir how much is your rent
uh it's about a thousand bucks okay I
want you to call your landlord and tell
him that you're going to pay him two
rent payments at the end of the month
that you can't pay him right now because
you got to keep your car from being
repoed okay sir and you call him before
when you get off the phone and tell him
that and he's not going to do anything
he's not gonna like it but you're gonna
pay him two payments at the first of the
month because you got enough coming in
to do that because you're making good
money you're just not made but it all
comes in at the end of the month right
yes sir okay and you only can do two
things right now with this with this
check eat
and get the car caught up because at 90
days they're gonna pick the car up man
yep you're at the repo point they are
not going to screw around you're gonna
look up there's gonna be no car in the
driveway and a wrecker running down your
street that's right where you are yeah
who do you owe this money too uh
you talking about the gambling debt no
the uh the car payment
oh uh just keeps the uh Federal Credit
Union okay
uh so that's a local credit union in
your area
oh yes sir uh I think they're based out
of Biloxi call them and see if you can
give them two payments out of this check
tomorrow and give you a little bit of
money to cut is your is your electric
bill behind too
um wait what was that is your
electricity and water behind as well
um so I have a roommate and he's taking
care of that and I've kind of filled
them in where I'm at and uh he's taking
care of some of the utilities I might
have to pay him back uh okay but uh all
right because here here's the here's the
rule you're looking for
okay food
shelter
clothing which you probably don't need
any of transportation and utilities
everyone else Waits until those are
current
food you eat not out to eat groceries
baloney hot dogs beans and rice
okay
food
utilities shelter which is rent and
transportation so you get this car
straightened up you get your landlord
straightened up you get your roommate
straightened up on the utilities before
we talk about paying anybody
I don't care who they are you got to
take care of your four walls of survival
before you move on to the next thing
does that make sense to you
it does absolutely it is the fastest way
to for you to get to these other people
now once your car is current what will
you owe on it
uh my balance is about 12 good and what
do you owe you have ten thousand dollars
on a gambling debt and what else
um I own I owe 900 to a friend of mine
uh who's running me some cash what else
so 1500 uh 1500 to a firm okay and
you're and your check at the end of the
month is going to be what 10 grand five
eight grand
roughly it fluctuates between about 8
500 so yeah so you're gonna be able to
clear up almost everyone but the big one
and your car
and by Christmas the big one and the car
are going to be cleared up no debt you
feel the chaos leaving your life feel
the order happening